we here at corridor love to pull back
the curtains on the filmmaking process
now a couple weeks ago we released the
attack on titan special that i'd been
working on and it went viral you guys
seemed to really enjoy it but we've
never actually shown you a
behind-the-scenes look at how i make
these videos that changes today because
in this video we're making the scale of
attack on titan enjoy
i'm i'm trying to write a video give me
some really complicated vfx
easy
give me something to write
so hard it's like that feeling when
you're trying to wrap your head around a
new concept and it hurts but it's just
like the whole time
that's yeah that's pretty much it it is
5 p.m
and i'm supposed to have a first draft
of this whole video written by end of
day today all of these videos i do like
they have a very very distinct and
unique style to them that i can't just
pass off it's why no one else ever edits
these videos for me i'm the only editor
that's problematic because then i'm not
a very fast editor
so the edit takes a while i've done so
many of these videos at this point and
yet every single video is always
different
they're always kind of similar
but always with very very different
problems and different solutions
required to solve those problems so
right why are you looking up images of
shirtless men well this is the dude that
the attack titan was designed after
really yeah physical proportions and
fighting style which i thought was kind
of cool i'm trying to find little
nuggets of gold that i think are really
fun facts you are five and a half times
more likely to be struck by lightning
than to be seven feet tall if we can get
that in the can at least we've started
okay uh clapsync sink clap venus
beetlejuice neptune alpha centauri solar
system sirius black check check one two
three titans are huge and they eat
pps but the average human male height is
five foot nine we got a truck the human
body struggles to work correctly when
it's this large the human body struggles
for the end of this take why is that the
human body struggles to work correctly
when it's this debate
but why is this
[Laughter]
i think when i take the red home
tomorrow to film this attack on titan
video with oh
coffee
[Music]
that's been sitting there a few days
what if i just recorded this entire
episode of vfx artists react with a
helmet on it's cause helmets are cool
right niko we just throw the red as a
soft spot in this skull cindy's wear
helmet everyday now
for anything i do
wearing a helmet doing mundane things
might seem kind of strange to you but
you know what's also strange not wearing
a helmet when you're one wheeling you
gotta protect your noggin
he just lies there and like i knew he
wasn't unconscious i'm just like he's
pissed off about something
either he landed on his shoulder it
really hurts her he just broke his
collarbone so jordan got him to the
pasadena hospital and then i'm like
trying to drive like really really slow
because like the bumps in l.a they suck
so bad so every time we go into a bump
he's like
and he's literally just like i can hear
it rolling around i can feel it like he
gets to visit jenna yeah he's visiting
his wife dude jenna is like the wife of
an air force test pilot yeah or she's
just waiting at home for the call he
said all he needed was his backpack i
asked him and then his keep card from
nikko there we go thank you much that's
just him he like got 13 broken bones as
a kid so
all right get home safe bye
[Music]
all in a day's work of being a
production assistant
hi
you look festive jan let me borrow this
i can't wear jackets so this is an
authentic mexican poncho from the desert
i guess it's story time huh i put away
my phone
then i tried to catch up with sam
overpowered the motor nose dived took
one step and just was on the ground i
programmed it so you can
play only with one hand
so yourself here
hey willy
this is my life for the next half year
i don't know exactly what this means for
the attack on titan video yet i'm gonna
get matt's help to
edit it
sorry i just had to shift a bone all
good don't worry about it first thing i
need are just those 2d images converted
to 3d models i know you said the cartoon
character might not work but give it a
shot anyway i will make sure you get
those elements matt you know what to do
just continue editing keep playing in
b-roll brent is very close to his edit
his editor is his child and that he
nurtures uh to
to a grown adult but a boy over there
broke his bones by the way if you have a
hundred dollars to spare you can get
around some new bones yeah what's up
with this back leg
well he's missing
knees
i'm gonna make a titan out of you like
in mulan as we all know in the show
these titans resemble
the people
that turn into them yeah i probably have
big eyes and i probably have like
like really overactive eyebrows let's
start by taking a photo of your face
okay three two one one profile three two
cool and i'll return to you with a titan
oh man that looks just like you
oh scarier sweet that's gonna be great
oh my god that scared me
what scared you i thought there was half
a person there
[Laughter]
right now is this one shot comparing the
different heights of animated and
real-life people and so i'm taking
photos of those characters and i'm using
a facebook algorithm to convert them
into 3d models and then doing a bit of
cleanup after the animated characters
have like brush strokes you just do a
little clone stampy wren what do you
think about this for the angle of the
shot it looks like balloon man i'm
feeling like we got this we can do it in
two days and finish it by wednesday
i can walk it like this it's like i can
move my arm this doesn't this doesn't
hurt uh but anytime i try to lift lift
my arm that hurts i will manage
i will persevere
i will keep moving forward this fight
sequence between the attack titan and
the armored titan is a chunkis sequence
this is like a huge scene that i hope to
have on like the level of like a
corridor short and what's your statement
on that
is it
um we'll take this next left here so
we're heading out
to a location
to shoot some drone shots
to set the stage for two titans battling
it out battling
to the death we have a perfect scale
because the attack titan is exactly the
size of that trailer right there i got a
piece of paper that makes me the a.d
we got we got nine shots to knock out
let's do it fast uh this is actually
good
interesting okay let's uh
let's see if that's a problem or not so
that was a colossal waste of time we
should head back
why oh
drone drone issue um
yeah so because this is a restricted
airspace area the drone won't even oh
yeah you know it does happen sometimes
where we set out to try to do something
like this where we shoot and it doesn't
quite work out we literally get nothing
and we just wasted the last you know 20
30 minutes of our day
so
[Music]
i didn't even get to have the things on
the list i wanted to do today not having
these drone shots yet is a huge problem
i'm not gonna give up
[Music]
no matter how much i want to
[Music]
that was a good little match cut there
kind of thought that he would like that
one so one of the downsides to a broken
clavicle is that it actually leads to
quite a bit of muscle knots in my
shoulder blade and my back and this this
helps really well for like kind of
getting rid of that
android exterminate
dude you just gave yourself a sternum
rub
everything you've done so far i think
looks great i'm very pleased i think
with this video we found the right sort
of
middle ground where i did all of the
initial editing got it to a point where
i can hand it off
and then you do all the hard work
okay great so that's what i love doing
uh my wife should be here in a minute to
pick me up
and then tomorrow first thing we're
gonna go get those drone shots drone
shots baby
[Music]
well matt and i have been trying to
figure out what to do for the intro to
the video because we needed something
that was more than just opening on the
anime you know any sort of
video essay on youtube opens very
generically like that and that's not my
style i hate that matt suggested what if
it opens with you sitting inside the
mouth of a titan i was immediately like
yes
even if he did have two arms at his
disposal wren he needs production's help
right now what he needs on camera is
some ambient occlusion my skill and my
favorite part is figuring out how to
make that happen in real life looks like
a mouth to me this is
literally exactly what i imagined last
night when i started suggesting it and
christian and jordan like literally made
it a reality it's amazing having
i'm producers excited for this shot this
is uh going to be a cool one the more
like subtle interesting creative details
you can add to something the richer it
gets
cilantro or lime juice dude this is the
cilantro of a vfx shot is adding like a
little brush just one extra little thing
to do it's the garnish and what it's
doing is telling a little mini story you
know on top of everything else it's
telling a story
in that you are
a titan hygienist man i just wanted to
tell you about my favorite anime attack
on titan
i love the brushing man i love not
explaining the brushing either it's like
we get it we just shot the thing we want
to add like some spittle
for the throat nonsense i'm using shape
keys to get the illusion of the throat
swelling and moving the shot was feeling
a bit stale and it needed some movement
and needed some life i added the throat
swelling without permission
[Applause]
i'm literally just two-thirds of his
height that he also had a foot long
for real real tough i read a lot about
this dude i never once saw that info
yeah interesting i had to look it up
specifically
i do appreciate that matt can make me
laugh that definitely helps improve my
mood if there's a goof that i'm adding
i'm adding it because it's something
that i think ren would find funny and
ren would want to add to the piece
anyway because it's his humor there's
also that challenge of finding a balance
between some kind of spice that you as
an editor or a filmmaker want to add and
staying true to
what the director's vision is it's super
important to kind of like marry those
two things if you don't do that then
you're just going off on a tangent
that ends up getting cut anyway
[Applause]
i have yet to see what i would look like
as a titan sam has made it and it's time
for me to see oh my god
so i like the mouth obviously i know for
your modesty i did paint out your
nipples yeah that is horrifying sam that
butt this is great
i didn't anticipate needing water
oh yeah should we double back no
we move forward
this is exactly where we shot portal
trick shots like literally
between these two pillars
all the tags have changed there's like
stuff in the street now there's cars now
back then there's like almost no one
around
action
part of why i love attack on titan so
much is that regardless of how dark the
story gets it's about perseverance it's
about not giving up in the face of
adversity regardless
i know yeah there's a lot of irony to
come about from this video considering
what has taken place here i have this
whole sequence planned out where i
literally talk about how to break a bone
[Music]
today's the day we do mocap for attack
on titan my hobbies include watching
attack on titan and playing around with
motion capture hardware so this is a
perfect combination ren was supposed to
do that mocap for the titan originally
but you know he had a little spill on
his one wheel so i had to go in for him
not exactly sure what challenges to
expect here other than probably just
trying to nail the fight itself maybe
throw your elbows out like you get up
and hold them there left this a little
lower and you lose control
nailed it what i want from you is very
different from what i asked to peter you
want this yeah you want the
i know the exact titanium
you're leading with your shoulders it's
always like
yeah the armor titan's all about having
that back leg like really stretched out
okay i love it that looks pretty
freaking perfect to me writing out those
titles that's normally just something i
do all myself i think it's very
important that it's at least my
handwriting doing it so what i did was i
basically wrote everything out onto a
piece of paper and i was able to hand
all of them over to matt so he can
actually do the filming of it this is
the first time wren has not touched this
process i want to take as much weight
off of him as possible i know what the
aesthetic is supposed to be what it's
supposed to look like he's in safe hands
so far it's looking pretty good
no no put it down put down
it's not allowed not yet
runs
that's all i'm allowing myself i just
needed a taste i just needed i just
needed a quick hit
that's all for now i'll i'll touch you
again next week and we'll do the same
thing not more not less ren what does
your t-shirt say
[Music]
i'm working on titans
dean's working on titans
renton is working on titans
and peter is working on titans it's
tight and weak the edits in place yeah
you know i always feel a little bit more
comfortable once i know
it's just effect shots left also this
time around i'll be able to work on some
effect shots
finally
i think i've delegated more for this
video than i even did for the up video
and that's not a bad thing
matt was able to bring a lot of cool
ideas to the table a lot of small subtle
touches to the edit that i may not have
thought of i'm like that's the best idea
i've ever seen in my life matt had a lot
of that i really enjoy running science
videos peter's greatest asset is his
ability and desire to over deliver he
always wants to make the best thing
possible which is great you want that
it's always easier to work on something
that you're a fan of sometimes it's
easier if the people that you're working
with
get you get your humor get your jokes
you have to be on the same wavelength
i'm gonna still try and have fun with it
i'm gonna still like have my input put
into it but ultimately my primary
audience when making the titan was ren
and that's why it's in ren's video i
made a firm
as a creator i do like the idea of the
sole ownership of the whole creative
process if i had my weight i would do
every single aspect of making these
videos and that's one of the biggest
challenges those soul creators
face if you get injured you're now
working at half capacity sometimes that
can be kind of devastating that's where
a team really comes in and helps out
because they can compensate that is what
teamwork is you have a teammate that's
down you pick them up give them a pat on
the back and say come on bud let's keep
going let's get through this and you
carry them you know it's ironic
i broke my collarbone two weeks ago
today
but in spite of all of the pain the last
two weeks have been probably the easiest
weeks i've had at work in a very long
time a lot of hard work a lot of long
hours but it's been like good work you
know like i've actually been enjoying
this
what is the last line of your video
part of why i love attack on titan so
much is that
regardless of how dark the story can get
it's about perseverance it's about not
giving up in the face of adversity
no matter what happens no matter what
happens no matter what happens
keep moving forward
[Applause]
man what a journey
man i miss onewheeling
oh
my god
if you didn't know this was actually an
episode of crew cuts a show on our
website corridor digital.com yeah i mean
if you like what we do and you want to
support us honestly subscribing to our
website is one of the best ways it's
like four bucks a month but get this you
can get the free trial for 14 days and
in that time watch every single video on
the website and then cancel your
subscription like whatever
that's the secret oops listen next week
we are doing another satisfying renders
challenge i wonder who will win honestly
if you made it this far more than
anything
thank you for sticking with us i'll see
you next sunday
and
three two one
we here at cordar love to pull back the
curtains on the filmmaking process
we here at corridor love to pro
let's get back there
we here at attack on titan
wow come on wow that was so close
nailed it